p autre fait beaucoup moins feutrées
celle des vendanges à suresnes dans les
hauts-de-seine la vigne d'un hectare a
été vendangée cette semaine et devrait
produire environ 14 hectolitres de vin
le seul de la région parisienne que l'on
peut trouver dans le commerce
et comme le veut la tradition la fête
est toujours l'occasion d'introniser des
personnalités cette année l'un de nos
illustres confrères a eu cet honneur
eric vers et philippe jarry de la robe
de la cuisse de la saveur et vous
reconnaissez l'humour de jean claude
bourret intronisé parmi d'autres
célébrités chevaliers de la confrérie
des vins de suresnes les vendanges sont
fêtés comme il se doit pour un cru 2004
qui devrait rivaliser avec celui de 2003
année faste pour les vins d'île de
france
il est très fruité il est à une jolie
robe
il est peut-être le meilleur cru que
nous ayons produit depuis maintenant 40
ans juste vendangé le cru 2004 est en
pleine fermentation 14 hectolitres pour
un seul cépage du chardonnet la question
pour l'instant de le boire
il ne sera commercialisé qu'en 2005 tout
va bien tout va bien être on est aux
alentours de 20 degrés on est à une
fermentation bien avancé puisque on en
arrive en densité 2020 donc ça se
termine sur les ceps de vigne il reste
encore quelques grappes de raisin mais
la majeure partie de la vendange est
déjà terminée un hectare qui pourrait
prendre de la valeur
dans la tente d'une appellation
d'origine contrôlée ou vins de pays
histoire de renouer avec la grande
époque de ce vignoble sacré meilleur vin
du royaume d'henri iv à louis xiv
en attendant le retour en grâce place à
la fête des vendanges sur rennes
boissons vins jusqu'à plus soif